hey guys in the official trailer for the
seventh season there's one shot that
shows you're a Greyjoy and delirious and
sharing a passionate kiss the shot
caused many fans to worry about the
others life which is not surprising the
last time we had seen Illyria sharing a
kiss with someone was in the season 5
finale and it's sealed merciless fate as
hilarya poisoned her with the kiss of
death hilarya poisoned Marcella with the
long farewell to a kiss and violet has
taken young girl's life Illyria took an
antidote and avoided the death the long
farewell is a poison originating from a
shy and as its name implies it takes
some time to take effect but it is
highly lethal it's the only known poison
whose antidote has been presented and
used successfully it is unclear how long
exactly takes the poison to take an
effect as Brown was imprisoned for hours
before receiving the antidote for the
wound in the arm caused by tyene and her
daggers coated with already mentioned
poison however well it took quite a time
for the poison to take effect on bran it
took only a few minutes to start taking
effect on Marcella
valid only daughter of Cersei in order
to start a war with the Lannisters and
to take vengeance for the Lannister
family's involvement in Auburn's death I
don't think you area would have any
reason to kill Yara
since both Illyria and Yara are fighting
for the same side hell declared for
Daenerys Targaryen when Daenerys has
assembled Armada finally sailed for
Westeros after six seasons of
preparations ships of Dorne are seen
among them supplied by Illyria it's most
certainly going to be interesting to see
how will Illyria react when she finds
out that merciless ankle Tyrion
Lannister who loved and sent his niece
in Dorne in the first place is now the
nurses hand who most likely demand
justice for his nieces and just murder
however adventures Salaria and fear
Ciara attracted in both men and women
and while there's a possibility that
they are simply having a good time in
this shot I don't think that's the case
additionally I don't think they are even
in a boat as I initially said that
they're in breakdown of the official
trailer in my opinion they're rather in
Seoul so the red cape and delirious lips
actually are coded with a fatal poison
it's already been confirmed by HB itself
that you don't Granger upon defeating
yar and the sand snakes in the fleet
battle earlier this season will capture
yara Larry and tyene whereupon he will
come to King's Landing to make a deal
with Cersei urine will come to King's
Landing and
with his prisoner sweet streets all the
way to the Red Keep and Oh pledged his
prisoners his army along with his iron
fleet Circe but in return Circe will
have to marry him
there's also a shot from one of game of
thrones promotional videos in which we
can clearly see Cersei confronting
imprisoned alaria in conclusion I think
there's a high possibility that Alerian
are stealing their own fates with the
kids of death in this particular shot in
order to avoid met Queens torture which
would anyhow eventually result with
their deaths and as always let me know
your opinion about all of this in the
comment section down below